[Music]
welcome back to fox and friends
the cdc is issuing new guidance on the
covid19 vaccine for people with
underlying health conditions saying they
can receive it provided they haven't had
any severe
allergic reactions to its key
ingredients fox news medical contributor
dr nicole sapphire is the author of
make america healthy again and she joins
us
now to react welcome nicole tell us
about these new guidelines
that's right rachel good morning um the
cdc came out because
people have a lot of questions about
these new vaccines specifically if you
can take a vaccine when you have chronic
illness well we know
with covet 19 the elderly and those with
pre-existing medical conditions
are at a higher risk for severe illness
so it's a really good question whether
or not those
with existing medical conditions can
take the vaccine
and when you look at the safety data
from pfizer moderna and some of the
other
vaccines that are going to be coming to
market they do include people with
chronic medical conditions which is a
good thing because about 40
of americans have some form of chronic
illness but they're usually including
the more common ones high blood pressure
cholesterol some
form of lung disease and they in that
they show that it's completely safe and
those people
absolutely should be getting the vaccine
what was not included in the clinical
trials were those with autoimmune
disease and some form of
immunosuppression and rightfully so you
usually don't include them
in the first stages of the of a clinical
trial however what the cdc and a lot of
the
specialty expert groups are coming out
saying is that the benefit far outweighs
the risks in these groups yes it hasn't
been tested in these groups
but it doesn't mean that the vaccine
isn't going to be safe the biggest
concern is
will the vaccine actually work in these
patients will it provide them the
immunity that they're going to need
rachel and as you know i myself have an
autoimmune disease and this was a big
question that i had
so i've called my my colleagues at the
fda the cdc as well as my own
rheumatologist and asked you know
can i get the vaccine will it put me
into a big autoimmune flare
will because of the medication i'm on
will i even mount an immune response to
the vaccine
and the answer is we don't really know
but what we do know is this vaccine is
incredibly safe
unless you have a known severe allergic
reaction history
so i everyone probably should be getting
this vaccine
under the guidance of their doctor and
we have clinical trials now undergoing
to make sure that these people are also
getting that immunity that they need
we don't know if it's going to be that
same 95 percent efficacy
but any sort of immunity is going to
help and really help us move that needle
with coven 19.
so you're going to take the the vaccine
nicole
so rachel when it is offered to me yes
the based on my
doctor's advice it seems that i should
be taking it
because it'll not only help me but help
potentially help those around me
and so when it is my turn i absolutely
will be taking it
all right so meanwhile fears are growing
that there's this new strain
of cova you know just as they're
starting to get a handle on covet 19.
talk to me a little bit about this new
strain
what we should be thinking about will
the vaccine that's out right now
first of all would that help someone if
they were to catch this new
strain this is a great question
rachel and a lot of people are concerned
about this but we do have to remember
that there have been over a hundred
different strains of sars cov2
circulating since the beginning of this
pandemic
it is completely normal and expected to
see various strains
emerge from um when you're in the middle
of a pandemic this specific strain
coming out of the uk which is now
not just in the uk it's all across the
the globe seeing it in canada as well
as close to home for us it does seem to
be more transmissible more contagious
there has not been data showing that it
is any more deadly or has any more
severe effects
the big questions are will our vaccines
work for it and moderna came out a
couple days ago saying that they believe
they have looked at this new strain
they have looked at their data that they
believe that the broad
immune response from their vaccine will
cover this strain
there are they're going to be working as
well as pfizer to start a
trial right now to make sure that it is
the same it's possible it's not going to
reach that same 95
efficacy but maybe it'll still be
provide 80
which by the way you have to remember
rachel we were just looking for anything
over 50
with these vaccines so the fact that we
got a 95
efficacy that's incredible